only on CBS this morning we have a very
happy update on a little girl's recovery
in the wake of a tragedy you may
remember this story it's been more than
two months since a gunman opened fire
along a roadway in and around Odessa
Texas seven people died that day and 22
were wounded among them was 17 month old
Anderson Davis who was shot while she
was sitting in her car seat
Matea vol visit her and her family at
their Texas home and she shows us why
they are actually not angry at the
shooter one bullet went through the back
of our car and it broke into pieces and
the shrapnel hit our daughter in the
face and chest
it's the moment every parent dreads
everything just happened so quick and
we're very confused I immediately start
trying to call 911 one we can't get
through the moment when your child is in
pain and you feel helpless for kelby and
Garrett Davis it was the day they nearly
lost their daughter Anderson the family
was running errands when a 36 year old
gunman outfitted with an ar-15 style
rifle opened fire killing seven people
there were more than 15 different crime
scenes and nine hundred eluded with
phone calls
forcing Kelby to get creative as they
waited for help she was bleeding and had
been hit in the face and so yeah I had
diapers luckily also for my floorboard
cuz our car is always messy so I just
started picking up diapers we're using
diapers to stop the bleeding yeah I was
just picking diapers up off the floor
and just just putting them all over her
chest over her face just trying to get
the bleeding to stop what happened when
that shrapnel hit her part of it went
into her chest
you know surgically had remove some of
that but it hit her in the mouth and so
that was the bad part is it went through
her bottom lip and knocked out her lower
right teeth and then her top left big
tooth part of it burned all the way
through her tongue
days after the shooting of visibly
shocked lb expressed her gratitude I'm
so grateful here I'm so thankful that
we're not one of those after a number of
successful surgeries in hospital stays
Anderson lost three of her teeth but is
now back at school with her twin brother
Rhett with all the anesthesia she's had
in different things they said just just
give a little time and she'll start
coming around and really about at that
six week mark it's like somebody's
flipped the switch and one day we're
sitting back there getting ready for
detective the daycare and we're like
this is it
like she's back have you guys thought
about what you're going to tell her
obviously she's one who's had to look
through a lot of the trauma of it I'm
very seriously I'm just gonna pray for
God to give me the words I think what
I'm most nervous for is the questions
that I can't answer
Anderson has years of physical healing
ahead of her but it's the uncertainty of
what happened here that keeps closure
far from reach do you think about the
shooter do you think like how could he
why would he do those questions run
through your head or do you not even go
there I don't blame anyone that has
anger here because I know everyone
processes it differently I honestly
don't feel anger I feel heartbroken that
a human could just end up at that point
in their life her smile looks different
it's just even more beautiful now
because we know all it's been through
and all it stands for and she's perfect
and we're thankful that she's doing
awesome yeah a beautiful ending for a
West Texas community devastated by
tragedy for CBS this morning media vdl
Odessa Texas that Smile really I admire
the mother that can seem to have
seemingly compassion for someone else as
opposed to anger
I remember marvel that she can do that
and to see the two of them together
those two little minimis ones very nice